I'm here in India in Mumbai what used to
be called Bombay behind me is the
gateway to India the entrance to the
continent I've come here to give
lectures at the Asian science camp and
at the University and to talk to Indian
chemists and scientists and find out
about Indian science
it's our first morning here in India and
we just going downstairs to meet dr.
Gopal and who's organizing our visit and
then to speak to the editor of the
journal Chemical Weekly so I'm really
quite excited so my interview I think
went quite well perhaps I talked a bit
much but now we're off to lunch we're
already late to meet some people from
the chemical industry here in India and
also a really famous chemical engineer
the father of chemical engineering in
India
so we here in new Mumbai at the opening
of the Asian science camp 2010 and some
of the important scientists are going to
make speeches before the real lectures
and exciting part begins I've come here
because I like talking to young people I
knew the organizers and it seemed a
really good opportunity to meet some of
the brightest students in their
chemistry from right across the world I
think in lecture power-cut quite
exciting I'm hoping for several things
first of all that my audiences would
enjoy themselves they should understand
what I'm saying
I'm hoping that I'll meet some new
people and perhaps set up some new
partnerships and collaborations
I'm here preparing for a talk from
test-tube to YouTube it's not really a
lecture it's what's called a temp I'm
going to try and get the students to
talk to you and see whether we can make
a youtube video during a lecture okay if
you can't hear me at any time wave you
as a group or an exception your people
who really like science which of the
explosions do you find most beautiful
and those exciting hi professor my
question is this if you could be any
element which would you be and why we're
in the indian national animal facility
nuclear magnetic resonance and they've
got some terrific machines here honored
guests ladies and gentlemen I'm
delighted to be here with the Asian
science camp and one of the speakers is
Professor Richard Ernst
the Nobel Prize winner and it's great
opportunity for me and Bradley to talk
to him I mean initially there was some
excitement but I mean people get used to
it and they recognize that I'm just a
normal person so I'm just getting ready
for my big lecture to all the students
and the room set out in a rather strange
way can you all can you all hear me I
don't know how many of you know what is
a forklift truck and the NH groups of
this growing in and it turned out I had
been wearing my wife's trousers
as you go on in life you will find that
there isn't just one person that helps
you but lots of people that help you
first of all for the physicist I have a
souvenir for my university for the
chemist I'd like to give them my time